the face transplant was divided into  three portions first a donor surgery  which entailed recovery of facial tissue  second the recipient surgery which  required removal of injured facial  tissue and finally the allograft inset  with the actual transfer of the donor  face to the recipient  recipient underwent surgery to recreate  a defect for precise adaptation of the  donor facial allograft this entailed  removal of all of the external scar  tissue throughout the scalp face eyelids  and ears mid-face Geller osteotomies  were designed in a manner to precisely  match the mid-face skeletal osteotomies  of the donor facial allograft the  remainder of the facial allograft was  read raped and tailored to completely  restore the entire recipient defect  including the scalp face eyelids ears  and skeletal subunits  you